people of Earth we are Decepticon  peacekeepers patrolling the galaxy we  believe a dangerous criminal from our  world is hiding somewhere on yours  there's a war raging on our planet  if be 127 isn't found that war may find  its way here  what I thought about the decepticons I  wanted them to evoke that feeling of the  80s better and dropkick were the first  to triple changers we've ever done in a  live-action film the idea to have triple  changers in this film came from the  original toy line that you could have  something that transforms into a robot  and one vehicle and then at a separate  vehicle and I think it's so fun to see  it in cinematic form we even leave that  dangerous criminal from all is hiding on  yours these two Decepticons the baddest  of the badasses I loved everything about  [Music]  you